how does someone who wants to become a
professional screenwriter approach it
like a professional screenwriter what is
their mindset what is their time like
what are they doing that's different
from someone who just says I want to be
a writer and both have equal talent but
one's approach and mindset is different
from the other one that yeah yeah I want
to be a writer but doesn't do that one
that's a really good question I had one
of my students or from online is now a
very very successful TV show runner and
soon to be directing a movie that she
wrote and I had her that's Lisa joy she
is co-executive producer Westworld and
she came to a class that I taught it in
Westwood for a weekend seminar and that
question they posed that question to her
and she said well I was working as a
lawyer and and before that was going to
law school and the way I approached it
was I'm going to act like I am a
professional screenwriter I'm going to
approach this like a job and so
obviously you know how do you do that in
terms of hours but set that aside that's
the mentality to have and you have to
really immerse yourself in it and it's
not just about writing the script it's
about learning the craft and so one of
those things that I came up with years
ago from my blog which is watch movies
read script write pages those three
things are absolutely essential you've
got to watch movies sometimes you just
kind of kick back and enjoy it but then
there are other times you stop it scene
by scene and you write a scene by seeing
breakdown and you're looking for where
the plot line points land the major
events that twist the plot in a new
direction you're looking at subplots and
those little many stories and my anti
stories and how they play into the to
the a story you're looking at characters
in terms of their transformation art so
there's watching movies and sometimes
you do it in a very rigorous fashion
then reading scripts Simoni you can just
sit there and just kind of blow through
a script and enjoy it but then you can
also do a same thing you can do a scene
by scene breakdown you're doing the same
sort of analysis that you would if
you're watching a movie reading scripts
is absolutely critical particularly
scripts written in the last five years
because the style changes constantly and
so people who tell you what you can't do
this you
do that much more important for you to
read scripts of professional writers
movie scripts where you are seeing how
professionals approach the writing and
you're then taking that knowledge and
bringing it to bear on your own writing
and then of course writing pages and you
know I have this thing I came up with my
blog that seems to be quite popular
which is one two seven fourteen one is
read one script per week two is watch
two movies per week seven is write one
page a day seven pages and 14 is 14
hours a week you should be basically 2
hours a day you are researching another
project you're rewriting a project
you're doing character development
you're doing story development you're
generating and assessing story ideas
you're tracking trends you're reading
the trades you know if you want to do
this if you really want to do this you
have to understand that you were
competing against people who are very
serious minded and have a lot of talent
it's not easy in fact the odds against
success are just enormous but the way to
do it is to approach it like you're a
professional and so if you can carve out
20 hours a week let's say 16 hours a
week you know 2 hours a day you know as
opposed to going and eating lunch you
know with the buddies for an hour and a
half 100 use that time to actually do
some work as a writer you know you need
to learn the craft and then exhibit what
you've learned on the page so that when
you've written that script it speaks to
someone you know someone will get it and
see that this is a professional writer
you